do you think Hunter caves on his dad I
think I think there's a theory out there
that I think is plausible of Hunter
deliberately releasing a lot of this
stuff in order to get back at his dad
for a potential crimes that Hunter
committed against uh the President
Hunter might actually be the hero yeah
you know he's like sitting there and
he's being like I could be a crackhead
but for the American people I'll make
the sacrifice he's good friends he's
good friends with Tucker Carlson what
Hunter yes look up Hunter Biden Tucker
Carlson you could see it they have a
good relationship with each other so
maybe potentially yeah
he's like giving all his information up
for money that's that's you know that
makes more sense to me uh money but also
maybe retribution maybe there's there's
something he calls his dad a pedo
apparently yeah that's listed as a
contact I could see like in 15 or 20
years after Joe Biden's passed away that
Hunter is like does a tell-all story
where he's like he was abusive he was
manipulative he got me involved in
Ukraine uh he put me in positions that I
didn't want to be